what is biden falling back on he is
falling back on just plain old class
warfare
and you know things are tired when
you're just going right back to the
class warfare gambit so here's joe biden
over the weekend doing his yeah i love
capitalism
but we're going to pay your fair
big corporations and super wealthy have
to start paying their fair share of
taxes
it's long overdue
i'm not to punish anyone i'm a
capitalist
if you can make a million or a billion
dollars that's great god bless you
all i'm asking is you pay
your fair
share
uh no that's not what you're asking so
you'll notice that the words fair share
tend to mean whatever rate i say for you
today
what exactly if you ever ask a democrat
what a fair share constitutes they'll
never give you a straight answer because
if they said you should pay your share
of for example the national income
people at the top of the income bracket
already pay more than their fair share
of the national income the top one
percent pays 40 percent of all income
taxes in america
the top 10 percent pay all of the net
income taxes in the united states like
beyond
receiving any benefits because if you're
very rich you don't receive any benefits
from the federal government basically
this notion that the rich don't pay
their fair share in the united states is
absurd the united states actually has
one of the most progressive tax systems
in the world in the world why
because all other countries have super
high tax rates for people who are in the
middle income brackets or the lower
income brackets even if you're living in
scandinavia you're getting taxed at like
60 if you're making 60 70 000 bucks a
year
all those social programs have a cost
so when joe biden says i'm a capitalist
but pay your fair share he doesn't mean
that he means i don't really like
capitalism all that much we understand
that it sort of pays the bills and what
i'd really like to do is just suck money
out of the people who actually are
earning a lot of money
to pay for my programs but not even to
pay for my programs cause i'm not gonna
pay for my programs i have no plans to
pay for my programs
all the class warfare stuff by the way
is just a shtick it's a it's a play for
the suckers okay all all the folks who
are at the bottom of the income spectrum
who look at joe biden and they look at
the aoc's the world and the bernie
sanders they say oh those are people who
are standing up for the little people
like me honestly at least bernie sanders
is honest he wants to screw the little
people directly he's like okay if you're
in the middle you should pay a 60 tax
rate okay more credit to him seriously
more credit to him
but if you're joe biden or aos you just
lie to people you're like oh well i'm
out there to soak the rich no you're not
you're out there to hang out with the
rich and take donations from the rich
and and hobnob with the rich and have
them pay for all of your campaign
that's what you're there for and then
you're there to yell at the rich every
so often so that you can sucker the
rubes into supporting you
it's all a game
and by the way if you didn't know it's
all a game let me just recommend that
you watch a little video of aoc okay so
there's a video of aoc going around
before she went to the met gala wearing
a
a very expensive dress that said tax the
rich on the back of it
okay this video is kind of astonishing
because all it is is her being treated
like princess die
you got a makeup artist she's got a
whole team she's got people she's got
people who are wearing tuxes around her
she's kind of dismissive of the little
people and then she walks in and all the
people are cheering for her and they all
understand that they're part of the gag
they don't feel like they're targeted by
her tax the rich dress they know that
they agree with her
they don't agree with her enough to
actually you know
not avoid the taxes but but they agree
with her on principle which that they
are the special people they are among
the specials
here's a little bit of that video
it's gonna be punk rock it's very punk
rock peak punk rock
[Music]
wasn't that jazzy and fun
guys wasn't that great
she was super sincere about it though
she's really sincere she really wants to
attach to tax all the rich people by the
way she really you know who she wants to
tax the most she really wants to tax
rich people like say like aurora james
and this lady is a really famous dress
designer apparently aurora james and she
needs to be taxed more because
apparently she's not only very wealthy
and runs a pretty large company but also
this person happens to be a notorious
deadbeat on taxes with unpaid debts
dogging her in multiple states
apparently right isn't that like a
perfect candidate for aoc to target in
her tax the rich dress oh sorry no sorry
aurora james made that dress
for aoc
and is the person who's been cheating on
her taxes apparently apparently she has
significant amounts in back taxes
most of her debts center around a
company she created in 2011 cultural
brokerage agency it serves as the parent
company to repair it to her current
fashion company the new york post
reports quote the company racked up
three open tax warrants in new york for
failing to withhold income taxes from
employees paychecks totaling 15 grand
the state department of taxation and
finance told the post the debt stemmed
from 2018 and 2019. the company has been
hit with 15 warrants in total since
2015.
the company got into an even deeper hole
with the feds between april 2018 and
april 2019 the irs placed six federal
liens on cultural brokerage agency
totaling over a hundred thousand dollars
the lien specifically cited the
company's failure to emit employee
payroll taxes
apparently that didn't stop james from
receiving 41 000 in pandemic relief aid
her company owes 63 000 in matters
related to workers comp her company has
allegedly relied heavily on legions of
unpaid interns working full-time jobs
wait i was told unpaid internships were
evil by aoc
that's that's crazy also james just
bought a 1.6 million dollar property in
california last year it's already listed
as delinquent by l.a county
because she apparently owes more than 2
500 bucks in a property tax
well so um
yeah so that so tax the rich except for
the lady who made this dress for the met
gala who hasn't paid her taxes but did
take federal money and who was
photographed with nancy remember how aoc
characterized her as a woman of color
living a victimized life in america
yeah man
it's all a game it's all a game to these
folks
by the way in case you don't believe
it's all the games of these folks
i'm just going to remind you that if
you're not special
the rule if you're not special then the
rules apply to you and if you are
special the rules don't apply to you
right if you are a mask-less san
francisco mayor you can party it up
if you're london breed the mayor of san
francis like how many
i i would say she should apologize but
there's no point you might end up
governor of california
and apparently immune to recall here's
london breed at a concert
right partying it up
good times in san francisco
nobody here is wearing a mask
now i've been told everyone needs to
wear a mask right even the vaccinated
but is anyone there wearing a mask nope
not a single one
not a single one the rules don't apply
to these people by the way the emmys
which happened last night i noticed that
no one was wearing a mask no one not a
single human was wearing a mask
amazing
apparently seth rogen who is the
presenter who's just an awful garbage of
a human he appeared baffled by the
indoor setting
because apparently it was supposed to
take place in an air-conditioned tent
but this was fully enclosed
he said i would not have come to this
why is there a roof but he did he stayed
and uh they all stayed there
unmasked but then again they're not you
know small children if you're a small
chill if you're a small child then you
must mask
if you're this video is going around
over the weekend of a small toddler
being forced to mask by a preschool
teacher
[Music]
there you go
still whines less than most democrats
but is subject to the rules because he's
a child
it's unbelievable unbelievable
it's just honestly it's just garbage and
it's unbelievable if you're london breed
the mayor of san francisco you can go to
a big party with a bunch of other adults
who are much more likely to infect each
other with serious illness
and uh if you're a child then we'll
force you to mask because you're not one
of the special people that is the way
that all of this works
and they don't hold to any real standard
about any of this
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang